こんにちは。はじめしゃちょーです。
結構最近ネットで話題になっている、超辛いグミ、ご存知でしょうか
何人かのYouTuberはもう動画にしてるんですけども、
こちら、リル....ニトロ....？ 何て読むんかな？
The World's Hottest GUMMY BEAR！🐻
もう、この中身、ほんとにバチクソ辛いらしくて、僕はもう見ただけで、恐怖で、
わたくし考えました
こんっなおいしいっ....いや...おいしくはないですよ？
こんな辛いもの、ただ食ってももったいないということで、
ちょっと楽しみながら食べれたらいいなと思いまして、
わたくし思いました、
グミベアー🐻くまの形をしたグミといえば
ワンチャン🐶、見分けつかないんじゃないかと思いまして、
ちょっと開けてみますね
まずこっち開けてみます
やばいよ、グミ１つにこんなことある？
でももうどう見てもハリボーグミだと思うんですよね
普通にハリボーグミと比較してみましょう
赤色の子を出してみましょう🐻
見て！
と、いうわけでわたくし思ったんですよ
この辛いグミ、ハリボーグミと見分けがつかないんで、
ここにもう大量にハリボーグミがあって
これを適当に紛らわしておいたら、ばれないんじゃないかと思いまいして
ちょっと今からまぎわらしてみますっ
はいっ。というわけで完成しました。
この、世界一辛いグミを３つ準備しました。
絶対、混ざっててもわかんないと思うんすよ
はい、もう入れますねほんとに
オレもわかんないくらい適当に入れときますよ
はい！もう完全にわかんないと思います
こんな恐ろしいものを使って今回は何をしようかといいますと
運が悪かったらたぶん
きっと今から来る2人は
果たして、そんなグミが超辛かったらどんな反応をするのでしょうか
さっそくやっていきましょう
ではいこう
やってまいりました、アメリカで大流行、
アメリカでめっちゃ流行ってるらしくて、
いや、俺たちなら絶対にチャレンジ成功できると思うんで、
頑張っていきまっしょう！
簡単なルール説明なんですけど、
負けた人がごっそり食べると。
ごっそりは自分でとるの？
そうそうそう。
平和すぎない？
ここにグミ1000個あるんですよ
1000個っていうのがチャレンジらしくて
で、勝てば食わなくていいから、
それで、どんだけ食えるかっていう挑戦
ひとり333個食えばいいだけですから
と、いうわけでやっていきましょうっ！
おっしゃい～！がんばりましょうはじめさん！
はい！がんばりまっしょう！
よーし、いくぞー！
手でかいからな
いや、そうなんだよ
はいはいはい、どうどうどう？
じゃ、いきますね
持った感じわかったんすか、口入んないなって、
よし、もういけるぞー
セーフ！？
セーフとかあんの？
アウトとかあるよ
アウトがある！？いきますね
どうでしょう
ああいいんじゃないんすか
いいですか？
いきますっ
いったなぁ
汚いと思うけど、食べれば大丈夫
ど、どうした？
結構な確率だよ、1000分の3だからね
セーフっ
やったー！
よっしゃー！
すげーこと期待してるよ、俺は
はい、ならしました
じゃあ、いきます
まぁ、どんどんいきましょう
どう見てもあいことかしてたでしょ
見てたでしょ、今の
これはおかしくないぞ、お前
混ぜるよ？
下の方からいけば？
いただきますっ
すっごい面白いんだけど、
さぁ、ちょっと数を減らして、確率を絞りましたっ
混ぜたいっ
これわかんない、ワンチャン2個食ってる可能性あるからね
たしかに、いるかは探したいところですよね
パッと見、舌で研磨した感じいませんね
お～！ナイスプレー
もうまって、この確率はやばい～
もう当たるよ、マジでさすがに～
平坦にしときました～
平坦でしょ、こっちからいくか、こっちからいくかでしょ
こうちょっとずついって、ここで、フュージョン
ご覧ください、こんな少ない、これ、やばいよ確率
30分の1くらいになってしまいました
もう、こんだけ少ないので2分の1にしましょう
右か左、どっちがいいですか？
というわけで、いよいよラストです
いきましょう
辛いの食べちゃった♪よっ♪
こわい、こわい、こわい
ダンスが、
ダンスがすごい